This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters,
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。我是Carrie Brownstein和Fred Armisen。90年代的梦想正以播客的形式重现。我们正在推出Podlandia AEO重温播客，这是一个全新的播客，我们将在其中一起重温Portlandia的每一集，剖析搞笑短剧，深入探讨我们的标志性角色，
and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song about it.
并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后故事。还将有帮助将这一切变为现实的人们加入我们。包括导演Jonathan Chrysler、市长本人Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家Amy Mann等在内的客串明星、合作者和朋友们。Kyle在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首关于它的歌。
Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.A.O. Rewatch on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports.
嗯，我还以为你们都要写首歌呢。我记得你是这么想的。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Podlandia AEO重温。最近怎么样，家人们？我是体育记者Ari Chambers。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？我是你们的女孩Sam J。我们是“每个人都看女子体育”的主持人。
A new podcast from Toge. Together in I Heart Women's Sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka showing out. Shout-hows to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rocks. Boxing journey.
这是来自Toge的一个新播客。Together与I Heart Women's Sports合作。我们正在剖析最大牌的头条新闻。大阪直美大放异彩。向你致敬，大阪直美。病毒式传播的时刻。我一直迷恋Kashan Rocks的拳击之旅。
She looks good. Her combos are swift. And the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast.
她看起来状态很好。她的组合拳很敏捷。以及整个女子体育界大家都在谈论的故事。因为每个人都看女子体育。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听“每个人都看女子体育”。
This is Chelsea Hamler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible. you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men.
我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉勒。每周，新闻都变得更糟。世界变得更疯狂。而亚曼尼卡在这里告诉任何该负责任的人。你才是问题所在。你知道我刚刚发现西德妮·斯威尼是谁吗？如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。
Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. My first guest is Territ Hilton, Shakira, Luke, and Yerrin. You have surprises? Many surprises. Mona. Welcome to the Sweet 305 Podcast.
要么表现得更好，要么少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是亚曼尼卡，我先走一步。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《You're the Problem with Yamanika》。我的第一位嘉宾是Territ Hilton、夏奇拉、卢克和Yerrin。你们有惊喜吗？很多惊喜。莫娜。欢迎来到甜蜜305播客。
where the group tech comes to life. What on? You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lle Pons on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Jake Brennan, and on my podcast, disgrace land.
群聊在这里变成了现实。怎么了？你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。这里是甜蜜305。在这里，过度分享受到鼓励。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听Lele Pons主持的Sweet 305。我是杰克·布伦南，在我的播客“丑闻之地”中，
I tell the stories behind music's biggest names, the moments that changed music history forever. Sonic Youth was cool, but was the band cooler than the couple on the cover of their album, GOO? Cool enough to escape the glare of the international paparazzi? Cool enough to escape murder? Disgraceland is part of the exactly right network. Listen to new episodes every Tuesday, bonus episodes Thursday, and rewinds on Sunday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the
我讲述了音乐界最大牌明星背后的故事，那些永远改变音乐历史的时刻。Sonic Youth很酷，但这个乐队比他们专辑《GOO》封面上的那对情侣更酷吗？酷到足以摆脱国际狗仔队的强光注视？酷到足以逃脱谋杀吗？《丑闻之地》是“绝对正确”网络的一部分。每周二收听新节目，周四收听额外节目，周日收听回顾节目，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。我是Gemma Spike，欢迎回到
the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. This episode is a rerun. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners. Old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we begin, I just want to let you know that this episode actually has two parts. It has basically like, I guess, a sister episode over on my other podcast mantra. So if you prefer a more kind of compact, succinct version of this episode to start your day or to start your week,
“二十几岁的心理学”，这是一个探讨我们二十几岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。本集是重播。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友。老听友，无论你在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一集，当然，我们要剖析二十几岁的心理学。在开始之前，我只想让大家知道，这一集其实有两个部分。它基本上就像，我猜，是我另一个播客《曼陀罗》的姊妹篇。所以，如果你更喜欢一种比较紧凑、简明版本的这一集来开始你的一天或开始你的一周，
I'm going to leave a link in the description of this episode for you guys to go and check it out. I would love if you just gave mantra a try. I'm sure if you love this podcast, you will love that podcast because it's basically the psychology of your 20s, but more spiritual, more philosophical, more meditative. So yeah, go check it out. But as for our topic, today, we're going to talk about confidence and what it is about confident people that is so alluring, so fabulous, and how we can emulate it, how we can cultivate this brilliant, bright, amazing attitude.
我会在这一集的简介中留下一条链接，供大家去查看。如果你能试听一下《曼陀罗》，我会很高兴的。我相信如果你喜欢这个播客，你也会喜欢那个播客，因为它基本上就是“二十几岁的心理学”，但更具灵性、更哲学、更有冥想意味。所以，去看看吧。至于我们的主题，今天，我们要谈论自信，以及自信的人究竟有什么魔力，为什么他们如此迷人、如此精彩，以及我们如何才能效仿它，如何才能培养这种出色、明亮、惊人的态度。
Because confidence, my friends, it's actually not something that you are born with. It is a skill, a skill that you can develop. One of my closest friends, Percy, actually inspired this episode, friend of the show, we love Percy. She is what seemingly, well, she seemingly is a very confident person. She just approaches every single social situation, every work present. every first date with just such a grounded, secure mindset. It's honestly, it's sexy.
因为自信，我的朋友们，实际上并不是天生就有的。它是一种技能，一种你可以培养的技能。我最要好的朋友之一珀西，实际上激发了这一集的灵感，节目之友，我们爱珀西。她是一个表面上看来，嗯，她看起来是一个非常自信的人。她对待每一个社交场合、每一场工作展示、每一次约会，都带着如此扎实、有安全感的心态。说实话，这太迷人了。
Like, she is so magnetic to watch. And sometimes I've even, like, found myself just being like, where did this come from? Like, who is this amazing woman? Because her confidence is like an aura. It's like a color that almost surrounds her. And I think it's so easy to observe people like her and conclude that she was simply born with this. This is always who she was going to become.
就像，看她那么有磁场。有时我甚至发现自己会想，这到底是从哪里来的？就像，这个了不起的女人是谁？因为她的自信就像一种光环。就像几乎环绕着她的颜色。而且我认为，观察像她这样的人并断言她生来就是这样，这是太容易得出结论了。这就是她注定要成为的人。
But the thing is, I've been friends with Percy for some time, for a long time, and I know her very well. And I know that this is not always what she was like. She was a very shy, reserved kid. I know she was bullied quite badly. I know she really struggled. And so it really got me thinking, what does she kind of know that we don't? Like, what is this formula that she has? What are the profound kind of psychological principles or shifts that delineate people who are
但问题是，我和珀西做朋友有一段时间了，很长时间了，我非常了解她。我知道她以前并不是这样的。她是一个非常害羞、内向的孩子。我知道她曾遭受过相当严重的霸凌。我知道她真的挣扎过。这真的让我开始思考，她到底知道什么是我们不知道的？就像，她有什么秘诀？究竟是什么深层的心理原则或转变，勾勒出了以下两类人的区别：
confident and people who are not confident? What is it about the history, their upbringing, their personality, whatever it is? And what about that can we change? What about ourselves can we kind of work with to come into any situation and just feel like we own the room, feel like we deserve and belong to be there? Because once we understand the science of confidence, once we kind of break down the myth that confidence is only something that you are born with, we really do become unstoppable. Like we become unstoppable in work, in romance, in friendship, in loving ourselves, in directing
自信的人和不自信的人。他们的历史、成长背景、个性到底是什么样的？以及其中有哪些是我们能够改变的？关于我们自己，我们可以着手处理哪些方面，从而能够应对任何情况，感觉自己掌控全场，觉得理应属于那里？因为一旦我们理解了自信的科学，一旦我们打破了自信是天生固有的迷思，我们真的就会变得势不可挡。我们在工作、浪漫、友情、爱自己、指引
our lives. You know, the list could go on and on and on. So where do we begin? What do we do? How do we get there? That is exactly what we are going to talk about today. Your formula for confidence. let's get into it.
生活方面都会变得势不可挡。你知道，这样的例子可以列举很多很多。那么我们从哪里开始？我们做什么？如何才能做到这一点？这正是我们今天要讨论的内容。你专属的自信秘籍。让我们开始吧。
So let's begin by dismantling this core assumption or core misconception, I should say, that confidence is a fixed personal attribute. You either have it or you don't. Is that true or not? Well, I'm going to give you the answer right now, and then I'm going to give you the explanation. The answer is, no, it's not. According to research, including a really comprehensive study
那么，让我们首先打破这个核心假设或核心误解，我应该这么说，即自信是一个固定的个人特质。要么你有，要么你没有。这是真的还是假的？好吧，我现在就给你答案，然后再给你解释。答案是，不，不是的。根据研究，包括一项在2021年进行的关于自信遗传性的非常全面的研究，
on the heritability of confidence conducted in 2021. Confidence is only between 9 to 28% heritable. What that means, if you don't understand genetics because sometimes I barely do, is that the majority of our confidence, somewhere between 72 and 91% is shaped by things like environment, experiences, mindset, choices, not just your genetics, not just things that feel outside of your orbit of control. For the most part, something like confidence is something that we can change. We can kind of intercept and form to our desires.
自信的遗传率仅在9%到28%之间。如果你不懂基因（因为有时我也几乎不懂），这意味着我们自信的大多数部分，即72%到91%之间，是由环境、经历、心态、选择等因素塑造的，而不仅仅是你的基因，不仅仅是那些感觉超出了你控制范围的事情。在很大程度上，像自信这样的东西是我们可以改变的。我们可以某种程度上进行干预并将其塑造为我们所渴望的模样。
And to truly understand why this is the case, and to truly understand the foundation of confidence, you have to understand one of its core ingredients, which is self-efficacy. Self-efficacy is a concept that was first named or labeled, I guess, by someone called Albert Bondura, a very famous social psychologist who we talk about a lot, and it is basically our belief in our capacity to execute the behaviours necessary to produce specific performance attainments. In simpler terms, because that is such a convoluted definition, it is your belief that you can successfully perform a given task, you can achieve a particular goal, you can, I guess, present yourself a specific way based on your intentions and you.
要真正理解为什么会这样，要真正理解自信的基础，你必须理解它的核心成分之一，那就是自我效能感。自我效能感这个概念最初是由一个叫阿尔伯特·班杜拉的人命名或标定的，他是一位非常著名的社会心理学家，我们经常谈到他，它基本上是我们对自己有能力执行产生特定绩效成果所需行为的信念。用更简单的话来说，因为这个定义太晦涩难懂了，它就是你相信自己能够成功执行某项任务、实现某个特定目标、我猜，能够根据你的意图和你的愿望以特定方式展现自己的信念。
your desires. It is not so much your belief that things will go well. It's not so much your belief that people will like you. It's not your belief in anything outside of your control. It is belief in yourself. Before we can become confident, we need self-efficacy. And the great thing about self-efficacy is that it can only be built and earned. It cannot just be granted to us. It is not either there or not the moment we are born. So there are four primary sources through which self-efficacy is developed and strengthened. When you understand these sources, you kind of precisely know how confidence is built in someone brick by brick through the process of learning and environment and experiences. So the first source, the very first one, is something called mastery experiences or inactive attainments. Basically,
它与其说你相信一切都会顺利，不如说你相信自己。它与其说你相信别人会喜欢你，不如说你相信任何超出你控制的事物。它是对你自己的信念。在我们变得自信之前，我们需要自我效能感。而自我效能感的好处在于，它只能通过建立和赢得来获得。它不能仅仅被恩赐给我们。它不是我们出生那一刻就存在或者不存在的。因此，自我效能感得以发展和加强主要有四个来源。当你理解了这些来源时，你就确切地知道了自信是如何通过学习、环境和经历的过程一点一砖地在一个人身上建立起来的。所以第一个来源，最初的那个，叫做精熟体验或亲历成就。基本上，
when you successfully perform a task, especially one that you initially found rather challenging, it creates a belief in your capabilities. This starts from like three months old. Let's use the example of learning how to ride a bike because it's a very good one. You know, riding a bike is kind of scary. Like it is kind of scary. Like you have to balance on these two wheels and you can go really, really fast and you'll probably fall off.
当你成功完成一项任务时，特别是当你最初觉得颇具挑战性的任务时，它会建立起对你能力的信念。这从大约三个月大就开始了。让我们以学骑自行车为例，因为这是一个很好的例子。你知道，骑自行车有点可怕。这确实有点可怕。你必须在这两个轮子上保持平衡，而且你可以骑得非常非常快，你可能会摔倒。
You know, the first few attempts involve. wobbling and falling and that erodes your confidence. But with each kind of like successful pedal stroke, each moment of balance, like your belief and your ability to ride independently grows stronger, it's all based on these moments of feeling like, I didn't believe I could do this, but I can. And that for our mind kind of acts as these concrete data points that rewire your internal narrative. It rewires your trust in your own abilities. The fact that you've kind of, you are capable. Now, the brain actively seeks and reinforces these positive experiences, which means that the next time you encounter something scary or new, the judgment of others,
你知道，最初的几次尝试包括摇晃和摔倒，这会侵蚀你的信心。但是随着每一次成功的蹬踏、每一个平衡的时刻，你独立骑行的信念和能力就会变得更强，这一切都基于这些感觉的时刻：我不相信我能做到，但我能做到。这对于我们的心灵来说，就像具体的数据库一样，重塑了你内部的叙事。它重塑了你对自己能力的信任。你是有能力的这个事实。现在，大脑积极寻找并强化这些积极的体验，这意味着下次你遇到可怕或新鲜的事情时，别人的评判，
the beginning of a new job, whatever it is, your brain kind of subconsciously looks back at these prior moments and goes, actually know like we are fully capable of managing this. These moments of mastery can be deliberately created. And that's really important because the more times you show yourself through trial and error and through believing in yourself that you can do something, the more confident you will become. Next, we have vicarious experiences or social modeling. We are, of course, inherently social beings, and we learn a tremendous amount by simply observing others. When you see someone similar to yourself successfully perform a task that you want to do, it can significantly strengthen your belief that you also possess the capabilities to master similar
新工作的开始，无论是什么，你的大脑都会潜意识地回想起这些之前的时刻，然后说，其实你知道，我们完全有能力应对这一切。这些精熟的时刻是可以刻意创造出来的。这真的很重要，因为你通过反复试验和相信自己向自己证明你能做某事的次数越多，你就会变得越自信。接下来，我们有替代性经验或社会建模。我们当然是天生的社会化生物，我们仅仅通过观察他人就能学到大量的东西。当你看到一个与你相似的人成功执行了你想做的事情时，它可以显著增强你同样具备掌握类似活动的潜能的信念。
activities. This is why mentors, role models, even peers are so crucial in building confidence. If you're a budding entrepreneur and you see someone from a similar background successfully launched their business, it sends a really powerful message. Like, if they can do it, maybe I can too. This actually really explains why representation matters and is so important for marginalized groups. There was a study done in 2016 in the UK and researchers asked high achieving university students from underrepresented backgrounds to basically send letters to students from similar backgrounds who were considering university and just talk about their experience, talk about the fact that it's possible. So there were over 11,000 people in this study. And these letters were really positive. They were like, shoot for the stars, you can do it, aim higher.
这就是为什么导师、榜样甚至同龄人在建立自信方面如此关键。如果你是一个崭露头角的创业者，你看到一个背景相似的人成功创办了他们的企业，这会传递出一个非常强的信息。就像，如果他们能做到，也许我也能。这其实很好地解释了为什么代表性很重要，以及为什么对边缘化群体如此重要。2016年在英国做过一项研究，研究人员让来自弱势背景的高成就大学生基本上给考虑上大学的类似背景的学生写信，只是谈谈他们的经历，谈谈这是可能的事实。因此，这项研究中有超过11000人。这些信件非常积极。他们说，志存高远，你能行，把目标定得更高。
And the researchers tracked students' application decisions and found that there was a significant increase in applications to more prestigious unies amongst the group that received the letters versus groups that did not. So this isn't about blind imitation. It's about seeing a pathway to success that is demonstrated. by others, which then informs your own sense of possibility. It's also why I think that we could do with more admiration in this society. Instead of being jealous of people who are, have what you want, or have the life that you want or who are doing better than you, these people can act as basically proof that your dreams, maybe aren't even that aren't big enough, because this person has managed to do it. Therefore, you can too. There is a pathway that is accessible. So confidence can be acquired through
研究人员追踪了学生的申请决定，发现与没有收到信件的群体相比，收到信件的群体向更知名大学提交的申请显著增加。所以这并非盲目模仿。这是关于看到他人展示通往成功的途径，从而启发你自己的可能性感。这也是为什么我认为在这个社会中我们可以有更多赞美。与其嫉妒那些拥有你想要的东西、拥有你想要的生活或者比你过得好的人，不如让这些人充当证明：你的梦想，也许甚至还不够宏大，因为这个人已经成功做到了。因此，你也可以。有一条可供通行的路径。所以自信可以通过观察以非常显著的方式获得。我们获得自我效能感的第三种方式是通过社会说服。所以这不是观察别人做某事。而是受到你钦佩的人的鼓励。有教练、父母、老师、朋友这样的人，他们可以说，你做得很好。你有能力做到这一点。
observation in a really significant way. The third way we gain self-efficacy is through social persuasion. So it's not observing someone else doing something. It's being encouraged by people who you admire. Having people like a coach, a parent, a teacher, a friend, someone that can say, you're doing a good job. You are capable of doing this. Positive feedback, it's truly so motivational because we really do like,
积极的反馈，真的太具激励性了，因为我们确实喜欢，外部的肯定，暗地里，但也并不那么暗地里。所以如果你有一个你钦佩的人说，哇，你真的在变好，你在进步，你做得很好，你其实准备好承受更多失败了。在某些情况下，你至少准备好承受更多失败了，因为你内心有一种奇怪的渴望去取得更多成功。你某种程度上让自己，你更频繁地面对应对机会的机会。你让自己走上通往成功的道路，通常即使你知道失败可能是一种可能性，因为即使在你失败的那些时刻，你也相信自己，因为你有这样一种强烈的感觉：尽管错失了机会，尽管自信心不足，但另一个人相信我，因此我可以相信我自己。
external validation, secretly, but also not secretly. And so if you have someone who you admire who was saying, like, wow, you really are getting better and you're improving and you're doing well, you're actually prepared to fail more. You're prepared to fail more, in some circumstances, at least, because you have this weird desire within you to succeed more. And you kind of put yourself, you kind of face opportunities more often. You put yourself in the path for success more, often even though you know that failure might be a possibility because you believe in yourself even in those moments when you do fail because you have this strong sense of someone else believes in me despite missed opportunities despite moments of ill confidence therefore i can believe in myself
也有相反的情况，那就是打击。其他人真的会让我们对自己的感觉糟糕透顶，从不以为然的父母到童年的霸凌者，你知道，我记得我以前有个老师对我非常非常刻薄。我当时想，你对我有意见吗？我才七岁字面意义上。我觉得自己真的很糟糕，记得感觉真的很不好，不想尝试，不想大声说话。打击和鼓励同样强大。这就是为什么周围环绕好人如此重要。如果你有一个非常糟糕的家庭，或者如果你被霸凌过，或者如果你真的觉得你的环境造就了现在的你，并且很难逃脱，要对抗这一点可能会很难。但随着年龄的增长，你确实有选择去和那些关心你、提升你、鼓励你的人在一起。
there's also the opposite which is discouragement other people can really make us feel terrible about ourselves from parents who are dismissive to childhood bullies you know i remember i had a teacher once who was really, really mean to me. And I was like, why do you have beef with me? Like, I'm literally seven years old. And I felt really, like, I remember feeling really bad about myself and not wanting to try and not wanting to speak up. Discouragement is equally as powerful as encouragement. That is why it is so important to surround yourself with good people. It may be hard to go up against this if you've had, you know, a family who was really awful, or if you were bullied or if you do feel like your environment is really what made you the way you were
你知道，如果你的朋友暗地里试图贬低你，或者如果你不断听取网民说的那些刻薄或残忍的话，或者如果你让家庭成员的话真正侵入你的心态，自信就会更难获得。幸运的是，我们还有最后一种自我效能感的来源要谈，
and it's hard to escape. But the older you get, you do have choices to be around people who will care about you, who will elevate you, who will encourage you. You know, if your friends are secretly trying to tear you down, or if you are constantly listening to what people online are saying that is mean or cruel, or if you let the words of your family members really invade your mindset, confidence it will be harder to obtain. Luckily, we have one final source of self-efficacy to talk about,
那就是我们管理自己对压力的情绪反应的能力。这是我们的生理和情绪状态。我们的情绪、压力水平，可以深刻地影响我们对自己成功潜力的判断。如果你感到平静、充满活力并为一项任务做好了身体上的准备，你会比深夜睡觉、喝了太多咖啡或饿肚子时更相信自己。这些选择很重要，而这些选择是你可以控制的。基本上，你如何应对压力，你如何学会与你的情绪建立联系，你如何为自己做好身体上的准备，都是你是否觉得自己有能力的因素。但这也意味着我们可以
and that's our ability to manage our own emotional reaction to stress. It's our physiological and emotional states. Our mood, our stress levels, that can profoundly influence how we judge our potential for success. If you're feeling calm, energized and physically prepared for a task, you will believe in yourself more than if you went to bed super late or if you have had too much coffee or you're hungry. These choices matter and these are choices that you have control over. Basically, how you approach stress, how you learn to relate to your emotions, how you physically prepare yourself is a factor in whether you feel capable. But that also means that we can
建立我们知道会让我们感到自信和感觉良好的日常习惯和传统，以此来为我们做准备，并抵消伴随着做新事情或在新人面前出现而产生的负面情绪状态。因此，当你理解了这四个来源时，就很清楚了，对吧，自信不是一种遗传特征。如果你持续寻找精熟的机会，如果你观察其他成功的人，如果你去到你受重视的地方，如果你学会管理你的焦虑和生理状态，你的自我效能，以及你的自信可能会增长。这里很重要的一点是谈论这样一个事实：虽然自信不是遗传的，
create routines and patterns and traditions that we know will make us feel confident and good as a way to prepare us and counteract negative emotional states that kind of come with doing new things or being in front of new people. So when you understand these four sources, it becomes really clear, right, that confidence isn't an inherited trait. If you consistently seek out opportunities for mastery, if you observe others who are successful, if you go where you are valued, if you learn how to manage your anxiety and your physiological state, your self-efficious, and therefore your confidence will likely grow. It is important here to talk about the fact that although confidence isn't inherited,
但它确实，你知道，非常深深地受到你的成长方式和身边人的影响。你知道，如果你，再次强调，有极其令人沮丧的父母。如果你在贫困中长大，如果你在导师、老师或没有成功榜样的陪伴下长大，你的起步点就会更难。我们必须对此完全诚实。这并不是要忽视这些劣势。如果我坐在这里说，每个人都从零开始，起点都一样，那我就是在玩忽职守。
it is, you know, really quite deeply influenced by how you were raised and who you grew up around. You know, if you, again, had parents who were deeply discouraging. If you grew up in poverty, if you grew up with, you know, mentors or teachers or no examples of success, you are starting from a harder point. And we have to be completely honest about that. It's not about ignoring those disadvantages. I would not be doing my job if I sat here and said, everyone starts from zero and starts at the same starting point.
你知道我的意思吗？每个人都有同等能力去建立自信，因为事实并非如此。但我真正想说的是，这是可能的。所以这并不是说如果你有过这些经历，你就彻底完蛋了。如果你被培养成习惯于贬低自己、对自己说丧气话，如果你对自己感觉不好，这些其实都是可以被逆转的。这些是别人加诸于你的。这意味着它们有一种抵消或平衡的作用，也可以作用于你，你可以对自己这样做，不是为了逆转这些事情，不是为了逆转
You know what I mean? And everyone has the equal ability to build confidence because it's just not the case. But what I'm really trying to say is that it is possible. So it's not like if you've had these experiences, you are completely doomed. if you have been raised to shrink yourself, to talk down to yourself, if you don't feel great about yourself, these are things that can actually be undone. They were done to you. That means that they have kind of like a counteracting or counterbalancing action that can also do upon you, that you can do upon yourself, not to reverse those things and to reverse
这些经历，而是去整合它们，并说你超越了它们。我稍后会多谈一点这个，但我认为这是一个在这里需要补充的重要限定条件。现在我们对自我效能有了一定了解，接下来我们还要谈谈自信是如何在一定程度上由你与自己的对话决定的。如果你想明白如何让自己相信自己是自信的，你必须知道卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）这个名字。她是斯坦福大学著名的心理学家，最优秀的心理学家之一，她发现我们关于智力和能力的思维模式只有两种，也确实只有两种根本性的思维模式。你可能以前听说过它们。
those experiences, but to integrate them and say that you are more than them. I'm going to talk a little bit more about that later on, but I think it's an important caveat it to add here. Now that we kind of understand self-efficacy, let's also talk about how confidence is in part dictated by the conversation that you have with yourself. If you want to understand how you can make yourself believe that you are confident, you have to know the name Carol Dweck. She is a renowned Stanford psychologist, one of the best, who discovered that there are two, and really only two fundamental mindsets we can have regarding our intelligence and our abilities. You've probably heard of them before.
你可能拥有固定型或成长型思维模式。拥有固定型思维模式的人认为，他们基本的能力、智力、自信，这些都是静态的特征。它们就是那样。他们生来如此。几乎没有什么可以改变它们。如果你擅长数学，那是因为你生来就擅长数学。如果你没有自信，那是因为你生来如此。
You can either have a fixed or a growth mindset. Someone with a fixed mindset believes that their basic abilities, their intelligence, their confidence, these are static traits. They are what they are. They were born that way. There's little that can be done to change them. if you're good at math, it's because you were born being good at math. If you don't have confidence, it's because that's how you were born.
没有什么你可以改变的。没有什么你能做来改变这一点。这种观点是自愿的。我知道这听起来很刺耳，但你确实选择这样去相信。这意味着，当你面对障碍，当你面对挫折，当你审视自己的自信水平并为此感到精疲力竭时，你不会觉得你可以改变它们。你会觉得你总是会这样。
There's nothing you can change. There's nothing you can do to change that. This kind of perspective is voluntary. I know it's going to sound harsh, but you do choose to believe that way. And so what that means is that when you face obstacles, when you face setbacks, when you look at your confidence levels and feel depleted by them, you don't feel like you can change them. You feel like you are always going to be this way.
相比之下，拥有成长型思维模式的人相信自己，同时也相信他们最基本的能力可以通过奉献、努力和练习来发展。而你的大脑、天赋、个性，都只是起点。换句话说，他们拥有我们所谓的内部控制点。他们相信自己有能力改变自己的行动，从而改变结果，但也能改变自己的命运。基本上，
In contrast, a person with a growth mindset believes in themselves, but also believes that their most basic abilities can be developed through dedication and hard work and practice. And your brain, talent, personality, those are just starting points. In other words, they have what we call an internal locus of control. they believe in their ability to change their actions and therefore an outcome, but also to change their fate. Basically,
当你相信：我有能力，我在拓展，我在学习，我在体验，我很自信。你就会那样做。你知道你如何看待自己的处境以及你如何看待自己
when you believe, I am capable, I am expanding, I am learning, I'm experiencing, I am confident. You act that way. You know that how you think about your situation and how you think about yourself
将会影响你自我的哪些部分得以生长和扩展，以及哪些部分，最终会萎缩。当然，现实要微妙得多。我们之前已经讨论过了。你知道，自信是一种技能。它是来自心态的东西。它不是天生就有的，
will influence what parts of yourself grow and expand and what parts, you know, ultimately shrink. The reality, of course, is more nuanced. We've kind of already talked about this. You know, confidence is a skill. It is something that comes from mindset. It isn't something that you're born with,
但我们天生所处的其他环境可能会使它变得更加困难。关键在于辨别什么时候你的心态可以战胜这些事情，什么时候不能。这就是为什么拥有自信的公式或者在工具箱里拥有技能和方法会真正有所帮助的原因，因为你不会仅仅对情况感到瘫痪，而是有选择去尝试，以对冲你的缺乏自信、对冲你的焦虑、对冲你的社交焦虑、对冲你的冒名顶替综合症或你觉得自己不配呆在那里的信念。所以这确实引出了我们今天最大的问题，
but there are other things that we are born into that can make it harder. What it's about discerning is really when your mindset can trump those things and when it cannot. And that's when having a formula for confidence or having skills and things in like your toolbox really helps because instead of just feeling paralyzed by situations, you do have options to try out to kind of counteract your lack of confidence, counteract your anxiety, counteract your social anxiety, counteract your imposter syndrome or your belief that you don't deserve to be there. So that really leads to the biggest question that we have today,
我们该怎么做？我不会就这么把大家留在这里而没有一些实用的技巧，包括世界上最自信的人的一些公式，你如何走进任何房间都感觉惊艳、不可动摇、完全做自己。这就是我们在短暂休息后要探索的内容。我喜欢吃得好。但在下班后、跑完差事后、处理完其他所有事情之后，做饭根本是不可能的。这就是为什么我开始使用Factor。Factor提供新鲜、从不冷冻、即食的餐点。
how do we do that? I'm not just going to leave you guys here without some practical tips, including the formulas of some of the most confident people in the world, how you can walk into any room feeling amazing, unshakable, completely yourself. That's what we're going to explore after this short break. I like to eat well. But after work, after errands, after everything else, cooking just doesn't happen. That's why I started using Factor. Factor delivers fresh, never frozen, ready to eat meals.
由营养师设计，提供均衡的营养，真正适合我的生活。无需准备，无需清理，只需加热、食用，然后继续生活。就这样，我找回了自己的时间。没有盘子，没有糟糕的选择，没有晚餐的压力。我不需要计划。不知何故，我仍然在吃烤三文鱼、奶油虾意面和美味的鸡肉饭碗这样的饭菜。吃起来就像是我精心烹制的一样，尽管，嗯，我并没有。Factor帮助我保持正轨。高蛋白、低碳水化合物、不含乳制品，无论目标是什么。现在，最高可省90加元并免运费。抓紧时间，此优惠不会持续太久，请访问factormeals.ca并使用代码easy。最高可减90加元并免运费，但仅限在factormeals.ca使用代码easy。Factor，加拿大排名第一的送餐服务。
Designed by dietitians for balanced nutrition that actually fits my life. prep, no cleanup, just heat, eat, and move on. And just like that, I get my time back. No dishes, no poor choices, no dinner stress. I don't have to plan. And somehow, I'm still eating meals like grilled salmon, creamy shrimp pasta, and flavorful chicken bowls. Food that tastes like I worked for it, even though, well, I didn't. Factor helps me stay on track. High protein, low carb, no dairy, whatever the goal. Right now, get up to $90 off and free shipping. Hurry, this offer won't last long, go to factormeals.ca and use code easy. That's up to $90 off and free shipping, but only with the code easy at factormeals.ca. Factor, Canada's number one meal delivery service.
你听过那些混乱。现在你可以看到了。我们想直接开始吗？在免费的IHeart Radio应用程序中，从头到尾观看所有你最喜欢的播客的完整视频。制造点动静。哦耶！在诸如“Bestie listen”之类的节目中捕捉每一个笑声和翻白眼。嘿，乔纳斯。我们只是叫作Cherasas。现在有了完整的视频。我把这个留在那儿。这是相同的主持人和相同的默契，所有你一直错过的爆笑时刻，就在你的屏幕上。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索视频播客并点击观看。
You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in? Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish right inside the free IHard Radio app. Make some noise. Wooee! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie listen. Hey Jonas. And We're just called Cherasas. Now with full video. I'll just leave that there. It's the same hosts and the same chemistry with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHart Radio app. Search video podcasts and tap watch.
最近怎么样，家人们？我是体育记者Ari Chambers。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？我是你们的女孩Sam J。我们是“每个人都看女子体育”的主持人，这是来自Together and IHart Women's Sports的一个新播客。因为说实话。女子体育这些天给我们带来了太多可以聊的话题。所以Kelsey Finler，她成为了第一位单人从加利福尼亚划船去夏威夷的女性独行划船手。我的第一反应是，零食怎么样？我们吃什么？集锦，竞争，崭露头角的明星，那些占据你整个时间轴的时刻。
What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all? It's your girl, Sam Jay. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and IHart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments that take over your entire timeline.
以及在比赛期间开始并且不知何故一整周都在持续的对话。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育界的最大故事。大阪直美大放异彩，她击败了萨巴伦卡。向你致敬，大阪直美。你赢得了赞誉，大阪直美。我的意思是，你为此赢得了一个赞誉。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。
And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out, she beat Sabalinka. Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. I mean, you get a palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it.
因为每个人都看女子体育。在IHeart radio应用程序、Apple podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听“每个人都看女子体育”。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。我是Carrie Brownstein和Fred Armisen。你们认识我们，或者说你们认识他们。托尼和坎迪斯，妮娜和兰斯，斯派克，还有，是的，那只鸡。
Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the Iheart radio app. Apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather you know them. Tony and Candace, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, the chicken.
这些年来我们扮演过很多标志性的角色，但今天我们以自己的身份出现，来向你们介绍Podlandia AEO重温，这是我们的全新播客。每周，我们都会从头开始重温一集的Portlandia。剖析搞笑短剧，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，重温你所知道和喜爱的波特兰拍摄地点，并坦诚我们的创作过程。这一切到底是怎么制作出来的？为什么我们当时会认为那是个好主意？我们准备好聊聊这个了。还将有帮助将这一切变为现实的人们加入我们。包括导演Jonathan Chrysler、市长本人Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家Amy Mann等在内的客串明星、合作者和朋友们。
We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, A.O. rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning. Breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann and many more.
Kyle在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有关于唱歌的能力。嗯，我以为他要写。我以为你们都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Podlandia。Ayo重温。我的第一位嘉宾是Paris Holtin、夏奇拉、卢克和Yerrin、萨米拉和格雷西。
Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song ability. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Paris Holtin, Shakira, Luke and Yerrin, Samira and Gracie.
我太兴奋了。在弹跳床上。你们有惊喜。很多惊喜。欢迎来到甜蜜305，群聊在这里变成了现实。怎么了。这就像是一种表达方式，哦，天哪，
I'm so excited. On a bouncy bed. You have surprises. Many surprises. Welcome to Sweet 305 where the group chat comes to life. What a . It's like a way to say like, Oh, my God,
你好，我的朋友，哦，我的兄弟。怎么了。看，我从来没有……除了我的孩子们，我的孩子们，我的孩子们，
Hello, my friend, Oh, my brother. What a . Look, I've never had to have I've ever been Except with my kids, my children, my children,
是的。C，我是一个男人，噢，是的，那是，那是不可思议的，你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。
yes. C, me a man, Oof, yeah, That's, that's incredible, you're the only person I know that loves a Yellow Starburst.
吃星爆糖。那是柠檬味的。不，有人说，我想和这个人合作。这里是甜蜜305。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方，收听Lele Pons主持的作为我的Coulthura播客网络一部分的Sweet 305。
at Starburst. It's lemonade. No, there's someone who says, I'd like to collaborate with this person. This is Sweet 305. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons as part of my Coulthura podcast network
自信确实是一场心理战，而这其中的好处在于，如果你有正确的心理策略，你可以把这些随身携带。你可以在任何情况下应用它们。如果你的大脑带上了，
on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcasts. Confidence is truly a mental game and the good thing about that is that if you have the right mental strategies, you can bring these with you everywhere. You can apply them in any situation. If your brain's coming
这些策略也随之而来。因此，我们心态的第一部分，是我们想要锁定的更深层的信念，即我们根本不配拥有自信，或者人们总是能看穿我们。他们总是把我们视作骗子。他们总是知道我们在假装。我们称这些想法，或者至少我称之为，自信阻碍者。你的想法是你自信和自我信念的强有力的建筑师。所以我确实需要你意识到你的自信阻碍者或你的内在批评者。当你在展现自己或尝试新事物时，你的内在批评者最喜欢的口头禅和最喜欢对你说的话是什么？
with you. These strategies are coming with you as well. So the first part of our mindset that we want to target are the deeper beliefs that we have that we don't deserve to be confident at all, or that people will always be able to see through us. They will always see us as a fraud. They will always know we're faking it. We call these thoughts, or at least I call them, confidence blockers. your thoughts are powerful architects of your confidence and of your self-belief. So I do need you to become aware of your confidence blockers or your inner critics. What is your inner critic's favorite catchphrase and favorite thing to tell you when you're putting yourself out there or trying something new?
大概是沿着你做不到这行路线的。你绝对会搞砸的。每个人都会知道你是个骗子。每个人都会看着你失败。首先，这不是真的。但当那些自我挫败的想法浮现时，有意识地暂停，然后开始质疑它们：那个想法真的100%准确吗？比如，你实际上有什么具体的证据证明这一点，又有什么证据反对它？你可以反击。你知道，你的内在批评者并不是唯一一个有声音的。你的内在啦啦队也有话要说。而且他们可以把话说得更大声。
Probably something along the lines of you can't do this. You're definitely going to mess it up. Everyone's going to know that you're a fraud. everyone's going to see you fail. Not true, firstly. But when those self-defeating thoughts surface consciously pause, then begin to question them, is that thought truly 100% accurate? Like what concrete evidence do you actually have for that and what evidence do you have against it? You can fight back. You know, your inner critic isn't the only one with the voice. Your inner cheerleader also has something to say. And they can say it.
他们可以大声尖叫。你可以选择你想相信关于未来以及你在未来所处位置的事情，因为它还没有发生。因此，尽管你的内在批评者希望你相信你会失败，你会让自己难堪，但它一无所知。它并不比你的内在啦啦队更清楚，因为后者认为你会做得绝对棒。所以每次你遇到自信阻碍者时，我都想让你重复这个口头禅。嗯，这一系列的口头禅：我是有磁性的。人们向我涌来。我的能量在我到达之前就打开了通往机会的大门。
louder. They can freaking scream it. You get to choose what you want to believe about the future and about where you sit in the future because it hasn't happened yet. So as much as your inner critic wants you to believe that you're going to fail and you're going to embarrass yourself, it has no idea. It has no more idea than your inner cheerleader who thinks that you're going to do absolutely amazing. So every time you encounter a confidence blocker, I want you to repeat this mantra. Well, this series of mantras, I'm magnetic. People flock to me. My energy, it opens doors before I arrive.
我在这个空间里穿行，坚定而有准备。我很冷静。我很沉着。我理应呆在这里。我很自信。任何版本的这个，任何一系列支持你、提升你、吸引你、并且（你知道的）迷住你的短语，我需要你准备好把它们砸向你的内在批评者。
I move through this space, steady and prepared. I am calm. I am collected. I deserve to be here. I am confident. Any version of this, any series of phrases that supports you and elevates you and which capture you and, you know, enthrall you, I need you to be ready to kind of like throw them at your inner critic.
我有点把它想象成抛出阳光球，每次一个阳光球击中你内在批评者的阴影时，它就会变得越来越小，然后它的某些部分像……溶解掉一样，无论什么能让它对你来说视觉化。像这样的积极自言自语是非常强大的。你和你的大脑有一种双向关系。你就是你对大脑所说的话。你变成了你对自己说的话和俗语。这是一个大致被称为语言相对论的过程。基本上，这个前提是，我们对自己和世界使用的语言不仅反映了我们的想法，而且实际上塑造了我们的思考方式。所以如果你对自己不断使用苛刻或限制性的语言，你可能会
I kind of think of it as like throwing balls of sunshine and like each time a ball of sunshine hits the shadow of your inner critic like it gets smaller and smaller and like parts of it like dissolve away whatever makes it visual for you. Positive self-talk like this is incredibly powerful. You and your brain have a two-way relationship. You are what you tell your brain. You become the words and the sayings that you speak to yourself. It's a process kind of loosely known as linguistic relativity. Basically, the premise of this is that the language that we use towards ourselves and towards the world doesn't just reflect what we're thinking, but actually shapes how we think. So if you are constantly using harsh or limiting language towards yourself, you may
我有点把它想象成抛出阳光球，每当一个阳光球击中你内心批判者的阴影时，它就会变得越来越小，其中的某些部分就像融化了一样，无论什么能让它在你的脑海中具象化。像这样的积极自我对话具有令人难以置信的力量。你和你的大脑之间存在着双向的关系。你就是你对大脑所说的话。你变成了你对自己说的话和俗语。这是一个被称为语言相对论的过程。基本上，这个前提是我们对自己和世界使用的语言不仅反映了我们的想法，而且实际上塑造了我们的思维方式。因此，如果你经常对自己使用严厉或限制性的语言，你可能会
literally narrow how you see the world and how you see yourself within it. Conversely, if you use empowering language, confident language, open language, you broaden your sense of agency, and you broaden your sense of the world. If you say to yourself, and sorry, I'm going to sound so repetitive here, but I promise I have a different point, if you say to yourself, I will succeed in this moment, I will be an image of confidence and power, that creates somewhat of a self-fulfilling prophecy,
字面上会限制你对世界的看法以及你在其中对自我的看法。相反，如果你使用赋能的、自信的、开放的语言，你就会拓宽你的自主感，并拓宽你对世界的感知。如果你对自己说——抱歉，我在这里听起来可能太重复了，但我保证我有不同的观点——如果你对自己说，此时此刻我一定会成功，我将成为自信和力量的化身，这就在某种程度上创造了一个自我实现的预言，
which we know is a psychologically proven and relevant concept because the expectations you set, especially through internal dialogue, influence your behavior in subliminal ways that often make your expectations come true. I also want you to sincerely ask yourself right now, why don't you deserve to be confident? Let's put on our investigator hat for a second.
我们知道这是一个经心理学证实的、相关的概念，因为你设定的期望，特别是通过内心对话，会以潜移默化的方式影响你的行为，通常会让你的期望成真。我还希望你现在真诚地问问自己，为什么你觉得自己不配拥有自信？让我们戴上侦探帽思考一秒钟。
Who convinced me that this is who I am? Who made me feel small? Who told me that I should shrink and that this is where I belong and I should be silent? And more importantly, what makes them right? Seriously, like what evidence do they have? Are they like the head of some like accredited committee? Have they been ordained to be able to do this?
是谁让我确信我就是这样的人？是谁让我觉得自己很渺小？是谁告诉我应该退缩，这才是我的归宿，我应该保持沉默？更重要的是，凭什么他们是对的？说真的，他们到底有什么证据？难道他们是什么权威委员会的负责人吗？他们是被授权可以这样做的人吗？
Do they have some degree or some authority and who's allowed to be confident? And who doesn't? No. They literally don't. They just have an opinion. And you can have a better opinion. You can have an opinion that's more accurate because you know yourself better than anyone. You know you're a good person.
他们有什么学位或权威吗？谁被允许自信？谁不被允许？不，他们根本没有。他们只是有一种观点。而你可以拥有更好的观点。你可以拥有一个更准确的观点，因为你比任何人都更了解你自己。你知道自己是个好人。
You know you're thoughtful. You know you're smart. You know that you have things to say and that you deserve success. you know that better than anyone because you have to live with yourself every single day and they don't. So you can choose to disagree not only with your inner critic but also with whoever it is, parent, family member, ex-boyfriend, ex-best friend who convinced you to be silent. Another incredible way to curate a confident mindset is through visualization. Visualization is so psychologically powerful.
你知道自己体贴周到。你知道自己很聪明。你知道自己有话要说，并且你配得上成功。你比任何人都清楚这一点，因为你每天都必须和自己生活在一起，而他们不用。所以你可以选择不同意，不仅不同意你的内在批判者，还要不同意无论是谁——父母、家庭成员、前男友、前闺蜜——那个说服你保持沉默的人。培养自信心态的另一个绝佳方法是可视化。可视化在心理上非常强大。
It's why we talk about it so much. Visualize how you want to enter a room before you enter it, and you will enter the room that way. Visualize how you want others to feel in your presence, and often they will feel that way. Visualize your voice being steady. Visualize the eye contact you'll make. Visualize your posture. Visualize your power. There are a few exercises to make this easier.
这就是为什么我们总是谈论它的原因。在进入一个房间之前，想象一下你想如何走进这个房间，你就会以那样的方式走进去。想象一下你希望别人在你的陪伴下作何感受，通常他们就会有那种感受。想象你的声音沉稳。想象你将进行的眼神交流。想象你的姿势。想象你的力量。有几个练习可以让这个过程变得更容易。
One I have spoken about before many times called the Golden Orb Theory. this is the one that I personally use. If you have ever met me at like a meetup or like on my book tour or at a live event, I promise you that I have been doing this when you have met me. This is what happens. I, before I enter into any room, I feel this nice golden orb in my heart. Obviously it's not there. We're visualising.
我以前多次谈到过其中一个叫做“金色光球理论”。这是我自己个人使用的方法。如果你曾在某个聚会、我的新书巡回签售会或某个现场活动中见过我，我向你保证，当你见到我时，我一直在这样做。事情是这样的：在我进入任何房间之前，我能感觉到我心里有一个美好的金色光球。显然它并不在那里，我们在做可视化。
But I imagine there is this like pulsating, beautiful baller. of light. And every time I breathe in and breathe out as I step into this room, it expands and expands and expands. Anytime I make eye contact with someone and have a conversation, that fuels it even more. And this ball, this orb just gets bigger and bigger and bigger so that anyone it touches, anyone who comes into contact with it, immediately feels comfortable, immediately feels tired to me, immediately feels, you know, good around me, immediately feels like their best self and I feel like my best self. And it's this visual way of imagining that I get to control how other people are feeling. Obviously, I don't, but I do get to control my own perception of their feelings.
但我想象那里有一个搏动的、美丽的、发光的球体。每当我吸气、呼气并走进这个房间时，它就在不断地扩张、扩张、扩张。每当我与某人进行眼神交流并交谈时，这就会为它注入更多的燃料。这个球、这个光球变得越来越大，以至于任何接触到它的人、任何与它有互动的人，都会立即感到舒适，立即感到与我紧密相连，立即感到，你知道的，在我身边感觉很好，立即觉得自己处于最佳状态，而我也觉得自己处于最佳状态。这是一种想象的视觉方式，让我能够掌控别人的感受。显然我并没有，但我确实能掌控自己对他们感受的感知。
And I know that sounds strange, but often with social anxiety or not feeling confident, it's not that you don't know that you can handle yourself. It's that you're overly worried with how other people are going to perceive you. So if you give yourself the illusion that you can change their perception, suddenly nothing else really matters and you feel the ability to be authentic and natural. And that's what this kind of activity and exercise really does for me. There's another one. It's known as the golden thread trick, golden orb theory, golden thread trick. You're seeing a theme. Basically, it's about imagining like a golden thread pulling from the top of your head into the sky. Instead of controlling you, it's elevating you. And it's making
我知道这听起来很奇怪，但通常对于社交焦虑或缺乏自信而言，并不是因为你不知道自己能应付局面，而是因为你过度担心别人会如何看待你。所以，如果你给自己一种“你可以改变他们的看法”的幻觉，突然之间其他一切真的都不重要了，你就会感觉到自己能够保持真实和自然。这就是这类活动和练习对我的真正作用。还有另一个方法，被称为“金线技巧”——金色光球理论，金线技巧，你看出规律了吧。基本上，它是关于想象有一根金线从你的头顶一直拉向天空。它不是在控制你，而是在提升你。它在确保
sure that you take up space. It's not going to let you slouch. It's not going to let you shrink. It's not going to let you shrink. it wants you to be present and you have like the permission from this golden string, this thing way up high going into the cosmos and beyond to be here and to be strong. You're drawing all of your power from it. There's also the very famous act as if technique. The act as if technique, it's a psychological strategy that involves behaving as if you already are the version of yourself you want to become. Confident, secure.
你占据空间。它不会让你驼背。它不会让你退缩。它不会让你萎缩。它希望你保持当下，你得到了这根金线的许可——这根直通宇宙及更远的高空之物——去存在，去变得坚强。你从中汲取了所有的力量。还有一个非常著名的“假装”技巧。“假装”技巧是一种心理策略，包括表现得好像你已经成为了你想成为的那个版本的自己。自信、有安全感、
successful grounded, you are already those things, even if you don't fully feel it yet. We talked about modeling before, and modeling really asks you to look at someone else who has what you have and to kind of emulate them. You can also kind of emulate yourself as well, right? Like, you can emulate a version of yourself that you think is incredible and who you want to become and who you can so clearly visualize. It's not about faking it. It's about rehearsing the reality that you're stepping into. And over time, the gap between who you are and who you're acting as if begins to close. And so you feel like that version of you is real.
成功、沉稳，你本来就是这些，即使你现在还没有完全感受到。我们之前讨论过建模，建模实际上是让你看看拥有你所拥有之物的人，并去效仿他们。你其实也可以效仿你自己，对吧？比如，你可以效仿一个你认为不可思议、你想成为、并且能清晰地可视化出来的版本的自己。这并不是假装，而是在彩排你即将迈入的现实。随着时间的推移，你现在的我和你假装成为的那个我之间的差距开始缩小。于是你会觉得那个版本的你是真实的。
It's like method acting almost, method acting for a future version of you that you want to become. Also, not to bring up modelling again, but if it's too hard to fake it, you don't have to. You can also borrow your confidence. You can borrow other people's innate ability. You can borrow their sense of satisfaction and pride in themselves. When you see someone that you really admire, think about the coolest person you know, like the coolest, most ambitious, amazing person, aspirational person you know,
这几乎就像是方法派表演，为你想要成为的未来版本的自己进行方法派表演。还有，倒不是想再次提起建模，但如果假装太难，你也不必非得这样做。你还可以借用你的自信。你可以借用其他人与生俱来的能力。你可以借用他们对自己的满足感和自豪感。当你看到一个你真正钦佩的人时，想想你知道的最酷的人，比如最酷、最具雄心壮志、最了不起、最令人向往的人，
think about everything that they would do in this situation that you're scared to be in. How would they hold themselves? How would they walk in? How would they speak? How would they communicate? How would they be? Think about that. Take it all and pretend that that's you.
想想在这个让你感到害怕的处境中，他们会怎么做。他们会如何保持仪态？他们会如何走进来？他们会如何说话？他们会如何沟通？他们会是怎样的状态？想想看。把这一切都吸收进来，并假装那就是你。
borrow what they have. There was a study that I read from 2021 that actually looked at how this is used to help train the confidence of young Olympic athletes or Olympic hopefuls. And there was a study done in Korea. And the researchers basically asked their participants who were people who would probably one day be in the Olympics to borrow their confidence from someone they admired. They were paired with an older team member or an older Olympic host. for or an Olympian even at that. And they were asked to think about them before they, you know,
借用他们所拥有的东西。我读过2021年的一项研究，它实际上探讨了如何利用这一点来帮助训练年轻奥运选手或奥运会预备役选手的自信。韩国曾做过一项研究。研究人员基本上要求他们的参与者（这些人可能有一天会参加奥运会）从他们钦佩的人那里借用自信。他们被与一个年长的团队成员或年长的奥运会选手甚至奥运冠军配对。
started swimming or dove off the diving board or did whatever sport they were doing. Think about them. Think about what they would do. Think about how they would stand. And their self-efficacy, which we know as a crucial ingredient, increased. Not only did their self-efficacy increase, they were also better able to really shift into a flow state. They were better able to cut through the noise of their own insecurity or their lack of self-belief and just be present in what they were doing. So just choose someone you admire, borrow what they have. Another step to mastering confidence and really building this skill like a muscle is putting yourself in situations where you can prove to yourself, you can cope. You can win. You can show up. You can be successful.
在他们开始游泳、从跳板上跳下或进行他们正在做的任何运动之前，要求他们去想想那些人。想想他们会怎么做。想想他们会如何站立。他们的自我效能感（我们知道这是个关键要素）增强了。不仅自我效能感增强了，他们还能够更好地真正进入心流状态。他们能够更好地穿透自身的不安全感或缺乏自信的噪音，只专注于他们正在做的事情。所以，只需选择一个你钦佩的人，借用他们所拥有的东西。掌握自信并将这种技能像肌肉一样真正建立起来的另一个步骤，是将自己置于能向自己证明你可以应对的情境中。你可以赢。你可以出现。你可以成功。
Basically find ways to experience small boost to your confidence, like those mastering. experiences we were talking about before. A lot of building confidence is actually exposure, like anything. If you have a social phobia, like how they treat most phobias is exposure. So if you have a social phobia or any kind of anxiety around specifically being around people, what someone is probably going to ask you, what a therapist is probably going to get you to do is to be in those spaces that terrify you the most as much as possible. If you are terrified of dating, you have to go on 10 first dates to win the challenge.
基本上就是寻找方法让你的自信心得到微小的提升，就像我们之前讨论过的精通体验一样。建立自信的很大一部分其实是暴露疗法，就像任何事情一样。如果你有社交恐惧症，大多数恐惧症的治疗方法就是暴露疗法。因此，如果你有社交恐惧症或任何围绕特定人群的焦虑，别人可能会要求你做的事、治疗师可能会让你做的事，就是尽可能多地去到那些让你感到最恐惧的空间里。如果你害怕约会，你就必须去进行10次初次约会来赢得挑战。
If you're scared of meeting strangers, you have to go to all these stranger events. If you're scared of giving presentations, you have to volunteer to do them. No skill ever is built simply by thinking about it. It's built through practice. It's built through stretching, pushing yourself. And you know what? That's really scary. It's really freaking scary.
如果你害怕遇到陌生人，你就必须去参加所有这些陌生人的活动。如果你害怕做演讲，你就必须主动报名去做。没有任何技能是通过单纯思考就能建立起来的。它是通过实践建立起来的。它是通过拉伸、逼迫自己建立起来的。你知道吗？这真的很可怕。这真的吓死人了。
It's also the only way to do it. I'm sorry to say. And then one day, not too long in the future, you'll suddenly find yourself being the person who is no longer at the beginning of this story, but, you know, halfway through it, who was able to turn around and say, I used to be someone who really struggled with this. I used to be someone who didn't want to date, who didn't want to put myself out there, who didn't want to wear these clothes.
这也是唯一的做法。我很抱歉这么说。然后有一天，在不久的将来，你会突然发现自己成为了这样一个人：你不再是这个故事的开端，而是处于故事的中途，能够转过身来说：“我曾经是一个在这方面苦苦挣扎的人。我曾经是一个不想约会、不想展现自己、不想穿这些衣服的人。”
And now I'm a success story because I put in the work. Finally, really consciously focus on your sphere of control. This is like the practical everyday application of cultivating a growth mindset and a strong locus of control. When you find yourself facing a challenge or a daunting situation or decision, you have to really ask yourself, what parts of this can I genuinely do something about? And what parts do I just have to accept or lean into? Then, critically direct your energy and your effort solely towards the things you can influence. your preparation, your effort, your belief, your learning, your attitude, how you choose to adapt,
而现在我是一个成功的故事，因为我付出了努力。最后，真正有意识地关注你的控制圈。这是培养成长型心态和强大控制点的实用日常应用。当你发现自己面临挑战、令人生畏的情况或决定时，你必须真正问自己：其中哪些部分是我能真正做点什么的？哪些部分是我只能接受或顺其自然的？然后，至关重要的是，将你的能量和精力完全集中在你能够影响的事情上。你的准备、你的努力、你的信念、你的学习、你的态度、你选择如何适应，
rather than wasting precious time and energy on things that are never going to be something you can change even if you try your hardest. One huge example of something you can't control, and this might surprise you, it's what other people choose to think of you. You may be thinking like, oh wait, what the heck, like, isn't that all we've been talking about, like all those exercises that you just told us, like wasn't that to control or influence what other people think? No, those aren't meant to change what they think. They're meant to change what you think. They're meant to change how you think about yourself. That is way more powerful than
而不是把宝贵的时间和精力浪费在那些无论你多么努力也永远无法改变的事情上。你无法控制的事物的一个巨大例子（这可能会让你感到惊讶），那就是别人选择如何看待你。你可能在想：“等等，搞什么鬼，难道这不正是我们一直在谈论的吗？你刚才告诉我们的所有那些练习，难道不是为了控制或影响别人的想法吗？”不，那些并不是为了改变他们的想法。它们是为了改变你的想法。它们是为了改变你对自己的看法。这要强大得多，
never trying to change or other people think of you. They're going to follow your example. How you think about yourself is how other people will often end up thinking about you. People can have whatever opinions they want as well. That's also not your business. You just can't can't control it and you will go mad trying to because trust me there will always be someone who has negative thoughts about everyone no matter who they are i think we've all been on the internet long enough to know this right you know literally think about like the coolest person on this planet like the most confident successful talented person i can tell you right now there is someone out there who doesn't like that person there is someone out there who could sit down with this person and have a
远胜于试图去改变别人对你的看法。他们会追随你的榜样。你如何看待自己，往往就是别人最终如何看待你。人们也可以拥有他们想要的任何观点。那也不是你的事。你就是无法控制它，如果你试图去控制它，你会发疯的，因为相信我，无论别人是谁，总会有人对所有人抱有负面看法。我想我们在互联网上呆的时间够久了，都明白这一点，对吧？你知道，字面上想想这个星球上最酷的人——最自信、成功、有才华的人——我可以现在告诉你，外面就是有人不喜欢那个人。外面就是有人可以和这个人坐在一起进行深入的交谈，却依然不喜欢他们。如果自信仅仅来自于别人喜欢你，那么没有人会拥有自信，因为每个人，所有人都有黑粉。所以，与其去对抗一堵坚不可摧的、代表着别人讨厌想法的红砖墙，不如专注于你的感受，你想从一个情境中得到什么，
big in-depth conversation and still not like them. If confidence only came from people liking you, no one would ever be confident because everyone, there is a hater for everyone out there. So instead of fighting against this like immovable brick wall that is someone else's nasty thoughts, focus on how you feel, what do you want from a situation,
你希望带着什么样的感受离开？记住，自信的人，他们不是那种光芒四射、完美无缺、对什么都擅长的人，他们往往是那些能够承认自己不擅长某些事情、能够寻求帮助的人。他们也知道会有人不喜欢他们，但他们知道什么在自己的控制范围内，那就是他们的心态。好了，我们要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，我有一些听众的问题，一些听众的困惑，全部都关于自信，所以请继续收听。我们稍作休息，
how do you want to leave feeling? Remember, people that are confident, they're not these like shiny, perfect, great at everything, people, they are often people who can admit when they're not great at things, they can ask for help. They also know that there will be people who don't like them, but they know what's in their control, which is their mindset. Okay, we are going to take another short break, but when we return, I have some listener questions, some listener dilemmas, all about confidence, so please stay with us. We will be right
马上回来。我喜欢吃得健康，但在下班、办完杂务、处理完所有事情之后，做饭根本无法实现。这就是我开始使用Factor的原因。Factor提供新鲜、从未冷冻、即食的餐食。由营养师设计，提供平衡的营养，真正适合我的生活。无需备餐，无需清理，只需加热、食用，然后继续生活。就这样，我找回了我的时间。没有碗盘要洗，没有糟糕的选择，没有晚餐压力的困扰。我不用做计划。而且不知何故，我依然能吃到烤三文鱼、奶油虾仁意面和风味鸡肉碗这样的美食。这些食物吃起来就像是我精心烹制的一样，尽管，好吧，我其实并没有。Factor帮我保持健康饮食。高蛋白、低碳水化合物、无乳制品，无论你的目标是什么。现在购买可享高达90美元的优惠并免运费。赶快行动，此优惠有限。请访问factormeals.ca并使用优惠码easy。最高可减免90美元并免运费，但仅限在factormeals.ca使用优惠码easy。Factor。加拿大的头号餐食配送服务。嘿，我是Ruby Carr，播客《OnCore》的主持人。
back after this short break. I like to eat well, but after work, after Aaron, after everything else, cooking just doesn't happen. That's why I started using Factor. Factor delivers fresh, never frozen, ready to eat meals. Designed by dietitians for balanced nutrition that actually fits my life. No prep, no cleanup, just heat, eat, and move on. And just like that, I get my time back. No dishes, no poor choices, no dinner stress. I don't have to plan. And somehow, I'm still eating meals like grilled salmon, creamy shrimp pasta, and flavorful chicken bowls. Food that tastes like I worked for. for it, even though, well, I didn't. Factor helps me stay on track. High protein, low carb, no dairy, whatever the goal. Right now, get up to $90 off and free shipping. Hurry, this offer won't last long. Go to factormeals.ca and use code easy. That's up to $90 off and free shipping, but only with the code easy at factormeals.ca. Factor. Canada's number one meal delivery service. Hey, I'm Ruby Carr, the host of the podcast, OnCore.
来看看我们的全新单集吧，其中包含了每个人现在都在津津乐道的那部剧中的音乐——《热烈竞争》（Heated rivalry）。和我一起深入探讨那些将Shane和Elia联系在一起的歌曲。我将为你讲述Fice、My Moon、My Man、Wolf for raids、I'll Believe in Anything以及纹身、所有她说过的话背后的故事，以及它们是如何成为这一全球现象的一部分的。在IHeart Radio、Crave或你获取播客的任何地方收听Encore。大家好，我是体育记者Ari Chambers。嘿，大家好，我是Sam J。
Check out our brand new episodes featuring music from the show that everyone is reheating as we speak. Heated rivalry. Join me as I go behind the songs that brought Shane and Elia together. I'll tell you the stories of Fice, My Moon, My Man, Wolf for raids, I'll Believe in Anything, and tattoos all the things she said, and how they all became a part of this global phenomenon. Stream Encore on IHeart Radio, Crave, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all? It's your girl, Sam J.
我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》（Everyone Watches Women's Sports）的主持人，这是一档来自Together和I Heart Women's Sports的全新播客。因为说实话，如今女子体育给我们提供了太多讨论的话题。Kelsey Finler成为了第一位从加利福尼亚独自划船到夏威夷的女性。我的第一反应是，零食怎么样？我们在吃什么？精彩集锦、宿敌对决、黑马新星、占据你整个时间线的时刻。以及在比赛期间开始、并且整周都在继续的讨论。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育领域的最大新闻。大阪直美大放异彩，她击败了萨巴伦卡。
And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is, like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments that take over your entire time. line. In the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out, she beat Sabalinka.
向你致敬，大阪直美。你赢得了掌声，大阪直美。你因此赢得了掌声。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣，我们还对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。
Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans.
这里是Carrie Brownstein和Fred Armisen。你们认识我们，或者说你们认识他们——Tony和Candace、Nina和Lance、Spike，还有，是的，小鸡（The Chicken）。多年来我们饰演了许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以自我的身份出现，来向你们介绍我们的全新播客《Podlandia：A.O.重看》（Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch）。每周，我们将从头开始重温一集《波特兰迪亚》（Portlandia），剖析其中的小品，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，重访你们熟悉并喜爱的波特兰拍摄地，并敞开心扉谈论我们的创作过程。
Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather you know them. Tony and Candace, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, The Chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process.
这一切到底是怎么拍出来的？你为什么觉得那是个好主意？我们准备好聊聊这些了。将帮助我们把这一切带入现实的人也将加入我们，包括客串明星、合作伙伴和朋友，比如导演Jonathan Chrysall、市长本人Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家Amy Mann等等。Kyle在这里火力全开。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌、一段旋律。
How did any of this get made? Why do you think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Man, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody.
我以为他会写歌。我以为你们所有人都会写歌。我记得你是这么想的。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Podlandia: A.O. Rewatch》。我的第一位嘉宾是Paris Holtan、Shakira、Luke和Yerrin、Samira以及Gracie。我在蹦床上超级兴奋。你们有惊喜。
I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Paris Holtan, Shakira, Luke and Yerrin, Samira, and Gracie. I'm so excited on the bouncy bed. You have surprises.
许多惊喜。欢迎来到Sweet 305，这里是群聊化为现实的地方。真他妈的。这就像是一种说法，比如，你好，美女（amiga），哦天哪，我的天。有什么！看，我从来没有过，我有过吗。
Many surprises. Welcome to Sweet 305, where the group chat comes to life. What a fuck. It's like a way of saying, like, hello, amiga, oh, my God, My mom. What are! Look, never I've ever had to have I've ever.
除了和我的孩子们，我的爱人（amante）。噢！是的，那是小说。你是我认识的唯一一个
Except with my my children, my amante. Uff! Yeah, that's the novel You're the only person I know
喜欢黄色Starburst糖果的人。那是柠檬味的。不，这有一个和这个人合作的小活动。这里是Sweet 305。与Lele Pons一起收听Sweet 305，
that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. And no, there's a little like to collaborate with this person. This is Sweet 305. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons
作为我文化播客网络的一部分，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎回来，各位。我们有一些听众的问题，直接来自于你们大家，也就是听众们。如果你想参与播客的这个环节，请确保在Instagram上关注我们的账号@thatpsychology podcast，这样你就能看到我何时为新单集发布
as part of my Culture Podcast Network on the IHard Radio app, Apple. podcast or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back, everybody. We have some listener questions coming straight from you guys, obviously, the listeners. If you want to be able to partake in this section of the podcast, make sure you are following us at that psychology podcast over on Instagram so that you can see when I put
问题收集箱了。本周的问题？太棒了。谢谢大家提出你们的问题。哇，听起来我像是个，我听起来像个学校老师。但是是的，谢谢你们问我一些非常酷、有趣的事情。让我们切入正题。这个问题，以这样或那样的形式，可能是被问得最多的。我真的很纠结，如果我太自信了，在工作场合及其他地方会不会显得自负。界限在哪里？你们很多人都想知道这个。
up question boxes for new episodes. Questions for this week? So good. Thank you guys for coming out with your question. on. Wow, I sound like, I sound like a school teacher. But yes, thank you for asking me some really cool, interesting things. Let's get into it. This question, in some form or another, was probably the most asked question. I really struggled that if I'm too confident, I will come off as cocky in work situations and beyond. Where is the line? So many of you wanted to know this.
自信与傲慢，或者说显得像个讨厌鬼之间的界限在哪里？这是一个太棒的问题。我认为你已经意识到这种可能性，这意味着你可能由于太在意而矫枉过正了，这实际上可能会产生相反的效果，意味着你比自己应得的更加压抑自己。我们想要找到一种真实的表达自信的方式，对吧？因此，重要的是要注意你在内心里真正的感受。把其他人抛开一秒钟。当你真正自信时，你可能会感到非常平静、警觉、
Where is the line between being confident and arrogant or coming off as a jerk? Such a great question. I think the fact that you are already aware of this possibility means that you are probably self-correcting too much because you're so conscious of it, which could actually be having the opposite effect of meaning you're shrinking yourself more than you deserve to. We want to find an authentic way of expressing confidence, right? And so what's important to notice is how you're really feeling in yourself. Don't think about others for a second. When you are truly confident, you probably feel very calm, you feel alert, you feel. grounded. When you are feeling arrogant, you feel tense, you feel anxious, you feel like you have
踏实。而当你感到傲慢时，你会感到紧张、焦虑，觉得你有
something to prove, you feel forceful. Learn to tell the two apart and to just stay in the first lane. When you are authentically confident, that comes off amazingly. When you feel grounded, it comes off amazingly. When you are anxious is when you actually end up being arrogant. So as long as you can tell the difference, I think you're pretty safe. I will also say I hate the way. word cocky, especially when it's used towards others to put them down. Like there are very, very, very few people who are genuinely arrogant and cocky. And yet people use that word to really keep other people small because it benefits them to do so or because they think that they should get to being control of how people act
需要证明的东西，你会显得咄咄逼人。学会区分这两者，并只停留在第一种状态。当你由内而外地自信时，效果会好得惊人。当你感到踏实时，效果会好得惊人。只有当你焦虑时，你最终才会显得傲慢。所以只要你能分辨出区别，我认为你就很安全。我也要说，我很讨厌“自负”（cocky）这个词，尤其是当它被用来打压其他人时。因为真正傲慢自负的人非常、非常、非常少。然而人们却使用这个词来贬低别人，因为这样做对他们有利，或者因为他们认为自己应该去控制别人的行为，
when it's not of their business. Often it is just a projection of how they think they themselves should act and therefore how everyone else should act because they've chosen to do it. but they don't really get to make the rules. No one does. Worry less about being seen as cocky and more about what feels right for you to share, what feels right for you to open up about what you want to say, how you want to act, how you feel in a situation.
而这根本不管他们的事。通常这只是一种投射，投射出他们认为自己应该如何行事，因此每个人都应该如何行事，因为他们自己选择这样做。但他们其实并没有资格制定规则。没有人可以。少担心自己被视为自负，多关注什么对你来说分享起来是对的，什么对你想敞开心扉、想说的话、想采取的行动、在特定情境下的感受来说是正确的。
If you feel strong and powerful, if you don't doubt yourself or question yourself and say things that genuinely feel true and meaningful, that is coming from a deep place. And if someone interprets that as cocky, you know that it's not your intention. and that's really the only explanation you need. Basically, if you're worried about coming off as arrogant or conceded,
如果你感觉坚强而有力，如果你不怀疑自己、不质疑自己，并说出那些真正让你觉得真实而有意义的话，那是源于一个深刻的内心。如果有人把这解读为自负，你知道这不是你的本意，
you are actually the person that I'd probably be worried least about because you have self-awareness and I don't think that truly arrogant people do. So you should be okay. Second question, another freaking banger. Why do we feel less confident in a group of very confident people? I think there are a few explanations. maybe I think firstly it feels like there's probably less space to take up less kind of like breathing room because everyone is like really demanding and asking for airtime probably also triggers a little
而这其实是你唯一需要的解释。基本上，如果你担心自己会显得傲慢或自大，
bit of imposter syndrome like these people have real reasons to be confident like these people really look like they believe in themselves i don't i'm just a fraud their confidence seems organic mine feels fake that's one take let's also talk about a more neurobiological side to things which is a bit more complex, but we often, I think, feel less confident in groups of highly confident people, not just because of imposter syndrome, but also because of dominance hierarchies. You know, we are deeply social animals that's encoded into our neurobiology. And from an evolutionary standpoint, entering a group meant having to be able to subconsciously assess where we sat in the social order. So like who's dominant, who's subordinate, who's safe to align with,
你其实是我最不用担心的人，因为你有自我意识，而我认为真正的傲慢的人是没有自我意识的。所以你应该没问题。第二个问题，又一个惊艳的问题。为什么我们在极度自信的人群中会感到不那么自信？我认为有几个解释。首先，我觉得可能感觉没有那么大的空间来展现自己，没有那么多的“喘息空间”，因为每个人都在强力要求获得发言时间。这可能也会引发一点
who feels like a friend, high confidence and high confident people signal dominance through their tone, their posture, their speech. They feel like they are leaders. And so our brain has to readjust where we sit. And that may interpret things as a challenge to our social standing, even if it's not, because we have these ancient brains in a modern setting. You know, there isn't just one person who's always in charge. There isn't just one leader who will dominate over others. There is more space. The important thing to also remember is that truly confident people, they are the ones who want others to thrive and they want to elevate you. Confident people have actually been shown to judge others less and they spend more time assessing themselves compared to other people.
冒名顶替综合征——这些人有真实的理由自信，这些人看起来真的很相信自己，而我不是，我只是个骗子。他们的自信看起来很天然，而我的感觉是假的。这是一种看法。让我们也谈谈更偏向神经生物学的一面，这要复杂一些。但我们常常在高度自信的人群中感到不自信，不仅是因为冒名顶替综合征，也是因为支配等级。你知道，我们是深度社交的动物，这已经编码在我们的神经生物学中了。从演化的角度来看，进入一个群体意味着必须能够在潜意识里评估我们在社会秩序中的位置。比如谁是支配者，谁是从属者，和谁结盟是安全的，
So actually in a room full of confident people, you are probably the safest you will ever be from judgment. So actually this is where you should feel free to be loud, take risk, tell stories, be who you want to be or thank you. If they judge you, that's something they have to address, not you. Next question, does being delusional actually help in elevating confidence? 100%. Yes, yes, yes. Being delusional can make you more confident. It's again, the language and the way that you're speaking to yourself.
谁感觉像朋友。高自信和高度自信的人通过他们的语气、姿态、言谈释放出支配地位的信号。他们感觉自己像领导者。所以我们的大脑必须重新调整我们的位置。这可能会将事情解读为对我们社会地位的挑战，即使事实并非如此，因为我们在现代环境中拥有着古老的大脑。你知道，并不只有一个永远掌权的人。并不只有一个领导者会支配其他人。有更多的空间。同样重要的是要记住，真正自信的人，他们才是那些希望别人蓬勃发展并想要提升你的人。事实证明，自信的人实际上对别人的判断更少，他们花更多的时间评估自己，而不是与他人比较。
It relates to that self-fulfilling prophecy that we kind of talked about before. If you, you know, feel like you can be something, if you just, so deeply believe it, chances are that you're more likely to act in a way that will make that happen. Kind of relating to the first question, though, there is a fine line here between delusion and narcissism and also delusion and actually putting in the work. Like, confidence is a skill, not a trait. That's the title of the episode. Skills require work. So saying like, this is going to happen to me, this is going to happen for me, all great things. You should believe in yourself. you should believe in your dreams, you also have to do something about them. You also have to find a way to
所以实际上，在一个充满自信的人的房间里，你可能处于最免受评判的安全地带。因此，这里正是你应该感到可以自由地大声说话、承担风险、讲故事、做你想成为的自己的地方。谢谢。如果他们评判你，那是他们需要解决的问题，而不是你的。下一个问题：妄想（being delusional）真的有助于提升自信吗？百分之百。是的，是的，是的。妄想可以让你更自信。这还是关于语言以及你对自己说话的方式。
take all of that really positive energy. Like that's a great starting point and make a plan, be willing to initiate, be willing to put yourself out there, be willing to be cringe, embarrassing, fail. That's what a really confident person would do. But yes, being delusional, 100% very helpful. Final question. How do I feel confident in a physical feature I can't change? I don't want to get surgery, slash I can't. So how do I embrace, if not truly learn to love this part of me? I really relate to this. Yeah, I really relate to this for a long time. There are things about myself that I really wanted to change. I still do. Here's the thing. We were not meant to be as conscious of our appearance as we are. Appearance was not meant to be such an important
它与我们之前讨论过的那个自我实现预言有关。如果你，你知道，觉得自己可以成为某种人，如果你只是，如此深信不疑，那么你更有可能以一种能让之成真的方式去行动。不过，结合第一个问题，这里在妄想与自恋之间、以及妄想与真正付出努力之间，存在着一条细微的界限。比如，自信是一种技能，而不是一种特质。这就是本集的标题。技能需要付出努力。所以如果说“这会发生在我身上，这会为我发生”，这些都很棒。你应该相信自己。你应该相信你的梦想，但你也必须为此采取行动。你也必须找到一种方法来
factor as it is in modern society. And so, of course, it's really hard. hard to love yourself when the thing a lot of us feel judged for first and foremost is by our looks. And it's not just that looks signal attractiveness anymore or fertility or whatever it was meant to. It signals wealth and it signals social standing and it signals all these other things that is just like making it such a confusing thing to manage. Oh my God, I saw this video the other day and not to judge this woman at all, but I saw this video of this woman who had sperm, like what was it? like fish sperm injected into her face.
将所有这些非常积极的能量——这是一个很好的起步点——转化为一个计划，愿意采取行动，愿意将自己展现出来，愿意去感到尴尬、出丑、失败。这才是真正自信的人会做的事。但话又说回来，保持妄想，百分之百非常有用。最后一个问题。当我无法改变自己的某个身体特征时，我该如何对它感到自信？我不想做手术，或者说我不能做。那么，如果无法真正学会爱这部分自己，我该如何接受它？我对此真的很有共鸣。是的，我长久以来对此真的很有共鸣。我身上有些地方我真的很想改变。我现在依然想。事情是这样的：我们本不该像现在这样对自己的外表如此敏感。外表本不该像在现代社会中那样成为一个如此重要的
And I was like, that, imagine telling someone like 6,000 years ago that that was something that was done. Like that sounds like medieval torture. And yet that's like something that people pay for to like stay young these days. And it's just the culture that we live in. No wonder everyone feels ugly.
因素。所以，当然，这真的很难。当许多人首先通过外表来评判我们时，爱自己是一件很难的事。而且外表不再仅仅标志着吸引力或生育能力，或它原本意味着的什么。它标志着财富，标志着社会地位，标志着所有这些其他的事情，让这一切变得如此令人困惑难以应对。天哪，我前几天看到一个视频——绝对不是为了评判这个女性——我看到这个视频，一个女人把精液，那是什么？就像是把
Like I don't know anyone who like truly just feels beautiful in themselves anymore. There's always something that an industry or a business or a brand is going to try and make you feel insecure about. So it's worth asking yourself, who taught me that this was a problem in the first place and what do they have to gain from making me feel bad? Often, you know, our discomfort is a mirror reflecting society's very narrow ideals. It's not an objective truth.
鱼精注射到她的脸上。当时我就想，想象一下在六千年前告诉别人那是做过的事。听起来就像中世纪的酷刑。然而这却是现在人们花钱为了保持年轻的东西。这就是我们生活的文化。难怪每个人都觉得自己丑。
Ugliness is actually not objective at all. Also just really start by softening the language. Shift from ugly to unusual. to unique to special, from embarrassing to mine, to whatever word you want to use that feels firstly neutral and then positive. You don't have to force yourself to love yourself right away. Aim for neutrality, aim for something that's a little bit easier and just saying this part of me, it exists, I don't need to shrink because of it. Also, how you look is really the least interesting thing about you. And I know I've said that so often and I'm sorry if you've heard it before,
我不认识任何真正对自己感到美丽的人了。总有一些行业、企业或品牌会试图让你对自己的外表感到不安全。所以值得问问自己：最初是谁教导我这是一个问题的？他们让我感觉糟糕能从中得到什么好处？通常，你知道，我们的不适感是一面镜子，折射出社会非常狭隘的理想。它不是客观的真理。
but if life was all about appearances, it would be very boring. And beauty does fade and beauty becomes something that people can only talk about for so long. So focus on the other areas of your life where you feel naturally confident and work on expanding them, work on thinking about them more, putting more time into those areas, celebrating them. Beauty and attractiveness, it is something we all live with obviously and have to consider and we exist in a system where that does matter, I'm not going to deny it, but how much do you want it to matter? How much do you want it to dictate the rest of your life? That's like a big question that I think is very existential and that you kind of have to answer for yourself.
丑陋其实一点也不客观。此外，真的可以从软化语言开始。从“丑陋”转变为“不寻常”，转变为“独特”、转变为“特别”，从“尴尬”转变为“我自己的”，不管你想用什么词，只要它先让人感到中立，然后感到积极。你不必强迫自己立刻爱上自己。以追求中立为目标，以追求稍微容易一点的事情为目标，只说我身上的这部分它存在，我不需要为此而退缩。另外，你的外表其实是你身上最不有趣的事情。我知道我经常这么说，如果你以前听过的话我很抱歉，
But I wish you the best of luck and know that I'm there with you and I've had many a similar thought. That is all we have time for today. My lovely listeners, I hope that this episode has given you something to think about and given you something to apply to your own. life. I hope you know confidence is a skill, not a trait. And with a skill, with any skill, it's something that you can improve in whatever area of your life you want to feel more like yourself and more for yourself. Leave your most like unhinged confidence tips in the comments below. If you have one that I haven't mentioned, let's let's share it. What's the thing that you do that like is just so weird and wacky, but always works and always makes you feel amazing,
但如果生活全都是外表，那将是非常无聊的。美貌会消逝，美貌也只会成为人们谈论一段时间的事物。所以，请专注于你生活中其他那些让你感到自然自信的领域，并致力于拓展它们，致力于更多地思考它们，在这些领域投入更多时间，庆祝它们。美貌与吸引力，这是我们显然都与之共存并必须考虑的事物，我们生活在一个它确实很重要的体制中，我不会否认这一点，但你希望它有多重要？你希望它决定你余生的程度有多大？这是一个我觉得非常存在主义的大问题，你必须为自己找到答案。
whether it's like a playlist, whether it's like whatever it is, like what is it? I want to know. Make sure again you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and let you share this episode with a friend, with a family member, with a colleague who you think could benefit from listening to it. Follow, subscribe, like, share, all those things. I always forget which order they're in, but you know the deal. It really helps the show grow.
但我祝你好运，并知道我和你在一起，我也曾有过许多相似的想法。这就是我们今天所有的全部时间。我可爱的听众们，我希望这一集能给你们带来一些思考，并给你们一些可以应用到自己生活中的启发。
It helps it reach new people. Also puts a smile on my face if that's something you may or may not want to do. But anyways, until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here.
我希望你们知道，自信是一种技能，而不是一种特质。而对于技能，任何技能，它都是你可以在你想要感觉更像你自己、为自己争取更多的生活的任何领域中提升的。请在下方的评论区留下你们最“疯狂”的自信小贴士。如果你有什么我没有提到的方法，让我们一起来分享吧。你有什么做法是那么诡异和古怪，但却总是管用，总是能让你感觉棒极了呢？
The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia A.O. rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped me. bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin,
无论是像一个播放列表，还是无论什么，到底是什么？我想知道。再次提醒，请确保在Instagram上关注我的账号@ThatPsychologyPodcast，并把这一集分享给你的朋友、家人、同事，你认为他们听了会受益的人。关注、订阅、点赞、分享，所有这些。我总是忘记它们的顺序，但你们懂得。这真的对节目的成长很有帮助。
legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts.
它能帮助节目触达新的人群。如果这是你想做或不想做的事，也能给我的脸上带来一个微笑。但无论如何，直到下次，保重。善良。对你自己温柔一点。我们很快、很快就会再聊。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。这里是Carrie Brownstein和Fred Armisen。
What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist, Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of Everyone Watches Women's Sports, a new podcast from Together and IHeart Women's Sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out. Shout out to you, Naomi.
大家好，家人们？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯。嘿，大家好！我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是一档由Together和IHeart Women's Sports联合推出的全新播客。我们将为您剖析最大的头条新闻。大坂直美表现亮眼。向你致敬，直美。
The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rocks, boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift. And the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
那些病毒式传播的瞬间。我一直对卡山·罗克斯的拳击之旅着迷。她看起来状态很好。她的组合拳很凌厉。还有大家在女子体育界热议的故事。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。
This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier, and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out.
我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都在恶化。世界变得更加疯狂，而亚马尼卡在这里告诉那些应该负责的人，你们就是问题所在。你知道我刚发现悉尼·斯威尼是谁吗？如果他能吸引一大群女人，那我也应该能吸引一大群男人。要么表现得更好，要么少做点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是亚马尼卡，我走了。
Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. My first guest is Paris Hilton, Shaquita, and eating. You have surprises. Many surprises. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast where the group check comes to life.
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听亚马尼卡的《你就是问题所在》。我的第一位嘉宾是帕丽斯·希尔顿、沙基塔和饮食。你们有惊喜。很多惊喜。欢迎来到《Sweet 305》播客，在这里，闺蜜群的聊天变成了现实。
What on? You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons on the IHeart Radio app,
怎么了？你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。这是《Sweet 305》。在这里，鼓励过度分享。在IHeartRadio应用上收听雷le·庞斯主持的《Sweet 305》、
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Jake Burn. And on the Disgraceland Podcast, I explore the wild, lives of rock stars and unbelievable true crime stories from music history. These are the stories you haven't heard, the kind you'll end up telling someone else. Like the time Paul McCartney spent in a notorious prison or the bizarre crime Lady Gaga is accused of, or that time Blondie's Debbie Harry escaped Ted Bundy.
苹果播客，或您获取播客的任何地方。我是杰克·伯恩。在《Disgraceland》播客中，我探索了摇滚明星们疯狂的生活以及音乐史上不可思议的真实犯罪故事。这些都是你从未听过 Stories，那种你会忍不住讲给别人听的故事。比如保罗·麦卡特尼在臭名昭著的监狱里度过的时间，或者Lady Gaga被指控的离奇罪行，或者雷蒙斯乐队的黛比·哈里逃脱泰德·邦迪魔爪的那次经历。
Listen to Disgraceland on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Disgraceland》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。